the person says I'm not really sure I'm  not sure if I want to move forward today  Etc we say is totally understand what if  this program were perfect would you do  it then they'll say yes you say awesome  well then what's the difference between  the perfect program in this program tell  me what's missing and what happens is  they'll have to generate responses and  usually people are not very good at  generating responses when it comes to  these types of things especially on the  spot and so a lot of times people  realize well I guess there isn't  anything missing and you say totally  understand that it might just be afraid  of making a mistake and I totally  understand too so why don't we talk  about what we have to make sure that you  don't feel that way and some of the  things that we do to ensure that you get  what you want fair enough great you can  close the deal if you're selling  services of any kind try this close